what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
wall street is trying to get rich so
russell bush is trying to get our lunch
money right
i'm here with the beautiful and
intelligent plane of evilova marinova
pompliano
p-i-m-p the reason why she's laughing is
because we just did
a first take usually it's one take and
we're done but during the first take i
had a
sneeze attack i don't know what's going
on
the yawning i already whooped the
yawning's butt and said get out of here
ain't yawning no more
he's attacked now sneezing is coming on
and it kind of took over a little bit
now to fight it back but we're all good
so uh don't forget that blockfi is now
the sponsor of lunch money you can go to
blockfy.com and get an interest bearing
account where you can earn up to 8.6
apy you can also use them for
crypto collateral to get a us dollar
loan or you can buy and sell crypto on
their crypto exchange with no
fees and they just announced today that
they have an otc desk if you
are rich and you want to buy a lot you
can go use their octc
desk all right go to blockfly.com what's
up
if you're rich and you want to buy a lot
of facts that's what otc desk is is for
rich people
guggenheim partners cio uh
said that bitcoin's bull run may have
peaked and the cryptocurrency could
suffer a significant
price pullback are we at the top
are we at the top of the roller coaster
listen let me explain some stuff to you
guys let me explain to you how wall
street works
he's gonna say this and then they're
going to buy some that's what that means
that that's translation like you ever
hear somebody speaking in another
language
like i don't know what they're saying
that somebody tells you like oh that
makes sense that's wall street speak
it may have peaked is wall street speak
for we're about to buy some
so here's the deal i think that if you
come out publicly and say we think the
price peaked you shouldn't be allowed to
buy anything
you're gonna buy some trust me i ain't
stupid you ain't i ain't selling my
bitcoin to wall street
but go ahead y'all wanna do that knock
yourself out they only
bought two million dollars with a
bitcoin when they previously said they
might buy up to 500 million dollars
at guggenheim so my guess is that
literally they're sitting here
price draws down they make a big big
purchase and it's going to come out in
the future sec filing that they bought a
bunch of bitcoin
watch you can mark it book it here's
your receipt
you'll see today is what's today's date
the 21st today's the 21st you're gonna
see watch
okay are you ready for the next one
trust in traditional media has declined
to an all-time
low and many news professionals are
determined to do something about it
56 percent of americans agree with the
statement that
journalists and reporters are purposely
trying to mislead people by saying
things they know
are false or gross exaggerations wow 58
think that most news organizations are
more concerned with supporting an
ideology or political position
than with informing the public
sorry when edelman re-polled americans
after the election the figures had
deteriorated even further
with 57 percent of democrats trusting
the media and only 18
republicans whoa it took a nosedive
so now do you think that the media is
not having a narrative of course they
have a narrative that's the point of the
media
well that's not the point of the media
it's to tell stories
yeah they're supposed to tell them
factually
but the problem in today's society is
that journalists have become activists
and as i tweeted previously
when journalists become activists it
forces everyone else to become an
activist as well
if you read these pieces
and you read what they are writing it is
not journalism
we have bloggers who have infiltrated
many of these legacy media organizations
and they're just spewing nonsense
it's just their opinion well guess what
i got an opinion too and they're no
different than me so let's go have
an idea clash uh an intellectual battle
of ideas
i think i think the reporters that you
are encountering online that have
all those political points of view those
aren't
to me those aren't true reporters those
are either
uh columnists or bloggers or
entertainers or
social media personalities uh i trust
people who report the facts regardless
of the ideology
um but here's the difference that i
think
has happened now in society is
historically like let's say in the
financial media
it was seen as a badge of honor to say
oh i'm a journalist i'm not biased i
don't own any of the assets i'm talking
about
we now live in a world where people say
no no no no
if you don't have skin in the game for
what you're saying i'm not
listening and so if you keep telling me
that you think the price of something's
going up or down
and you can constantly share your
opinion without penalty when you're
wrong
meaning you won't get fired and you
don't lose any money
then you're just yeah you don't actually
believe what you're saying
and so that's that's the world that
we're headed to but you're you're
forcing
journalists to become activists by
saying you need skin in the game like
that no
what i'm saying is if you write a piece
that says
x asset is gonna go up or down or
market's gonna do something and you can
just make
wild predictions and opine on whatever
your personal opinion is and you have no
skin in the game
no one should listen to you if you just
want to report facts and just say hey
this is what happened and i'm not going
to opine on fu on the future
that's different but what we have is
nobody wants to read
factual news everyone wants to read all
the
all the like crazy predictions and and
the opinions and the
like controversy and salacious headlines
and so that's
naturally the incentive is for people
who work in the media to write that
stuff
so it pulls them away from journalism
into this blogosphere
and so i've always broken it down
there's journalists there's bloggers
working at media companies and then
there's the actual market participants
if you are not a journalist conducting
journalism
or you are not a market participant with
real skin in the game
then you're just a blogger and guess
what that's fine that that's perfectly
within your right to just write your
opinion
but also people should assign just as
much importance to that
as it has which is zero you're just a
blocker like what's in between you an
anonymous account on twitter nothing
you're just opining on a bunch of
garbage go ahead
paulina is not very happy with that
perspective that i no
i'm fine with it i just miss journalism
yeah i do too who do you think is doing
the best journalism right now
that's a good question like a media
organization or a person uh either one
whichever one you would call the profile
oh that was good that was a
that was a uh a softball you hit it out
of the park
you want to show everyone how you swing
a baseball bat
boom also how you swing a golf ball
bat go golf ball
club shut that up
explain to people how the first time
that we were going to go to a golfing
event which was not a real golf it was
literally top golf
polina didn't realize you hit the ball
off the ground no i knew that i just i
was like i'm gonna
hit a home run and then that's how i hit
it if you guys watch my video on twitter
okay moving on jay-z joins the push to
boost
minority-owned cannabis businesses by
putting his money where his mouth is
jay-z is launching a fund to invest in
minority-owned cannabis startups
to bolster black participation in the
industry he thinks cannabis is
the future uh mr carter
who is starting his fund with 10 million
dollars in seed money
received as part of a merger joins a
broader push for equitable
economic opportunities in the cannabis
sector
i think this is cool i love this jay-z
is a business
man he's just basically empowering other
business owners
in the cannabis space i wonder do you
think jay-z knows about bitcoin
yeah absolutely really yeah joe budden
talked about it on the podcast
um the other thing that i would say
about jay-z and he says it in here see
we were the ones most negatively
affected by the war on drugs meaning
people of color
and so uh i think that there's a huge
argument to be made like look
if you're basically going to go after
the urban kind of communities
and over police them and kind of do all
this crazy stuff you put all those
people in jail but now it's legal
what i'm waiting for is when uh
marijuana gets legalized at the federal
level which i think should happen
immediately
uh but whenever it happens uh what are
they gonna do they can let everyone out
of jail
they should i think so imagine being in
jail for a crime that's no longer a
crime
it's pretty crazy all right next tyson
do you guys remember the chicken drama
of yesteryear
yeah i remember tyson food said it has
agreed to pay 221.5
million dollars to settle with plaintiff
groups of poultry buyers that suited for
price fixing claims
controversy in the chicken business
chicken wars
helping resolve a four-year legal battle
that over alleged collusion in the 65
billion dollar chicken industry i mean
there probably is collusion the chicken
industry seems like a place that there
would be some collusion
do you remember the chicken balls early
in the pandemic when beef was
like gone pelina has passed a chicken
walking
around here in michigan i love this
chicken oh they don't care about pelina
it just walks right by
just like strutting its stuff just
walking right by and it's so cocky
no pun intended um but we were
it's it lives at the grocery store and
it just like walks around should we tell
people how we went to a restaurant
uh two weeks ago and we were sitting
outside and next thing i know
polina is feeding the birds she's
literally taking pieces of bread and
giving the birds
loved me those birds one of them was
really stupid and
i kept trying to feed it and then all
the other ones would swoop in and i was
like well it's
your own fault really well that's why it
was the brunt of the group is because
that would never didn't have this
i just love that one no it couldn't fly
i think okay
a woman a toronto woman has used the
same lottery number since they came to
her husband in a dream two decades ago
and she won
a 50 million dollar jackpot in the
lottery with them
huh you don't know this about me pretty
interesting but when i was very little
they told me to like fill out a thing
and i won five out of six numbers in the
lottery but then bulgaria was being
stupid and was like
oh one of them is smudged we don't
really believe it
and they gave us a four out of six which
wasn't nearly as much as five out of six
but i'm just saying
i'm i was lucky once how about how have
you done since
i haven't played but maybe i should play
that's fine we can go get lottery
tickets today and we'll see if we win
i'll make you guys a deal if you think
that we should get lottery tickets i'll
split the winnings if we win anything
with all of you
yeah but what if we went like two
dollars well then i'm gonna keep the two
dollars
all right but if we win a lot of money
imagine if we threw a lunch money party
and we flew as many people as possible
in another in other
lottery news a single powerball ticket
purchased in maryland
is worth 731.1 million dollars
after growing for four months with no
big winner the top prize was snagged
wednesday night
still up for grabs is the mega millions
jackpot which also has been growing and
it's an estimated 970 million dollars we
should play that one
that that's this product yeah i don't
condone gambling but you know
i like asymmetric payoffs and so the
chance of a single ticket matching all
six numbers in powerball is one in 292
million
oh i got a good shot then all right that
sounds good to me
let's go buy it that's it powerball
powerball
yeah but somebody hit the other one that
person got
they got the smaller uh let's go
maryland yeah i'm gonna go after the
billion dollars can you imagine if i got
a billion dollar you know what i would
do with it they take it all intact you
know what i would do with it no
you guys know you don't know
no you'd give it to the lunch money no
viewers no i give 50 to the lunch money
people
and you know what i do the other 50 what
well i wouldn't want them to erode my
purchasing power so i would have to
protect it by
putting investing in bitcoin converting
it it's not investing i'd be converting
it into bitcoin go ahead
okay it's ask lunch money time ask
lm in the comments below from nba
insider anthony i would like to start
creating tv style sports content on
youtube or any other major platform
i'm already performing successfully on
youtube creating 30 minute support
related episodes with many comparing my
content to a netflix espn style creation
that's cool
but i'm just a one-man team what would
you recommend to someone who has no
financial means of bringing their
business vision to the next level and no
history of raising equity
how would you going how would you go
about doing this
don't raise money don't raise money have
your customers finance it i would go and
i would find a sponsor
and i would say to them hey here's what
i've been doing here's what i want to do
i want to pre-sell you the show
i want you to pay me for six months or
12 months and i want you to pay me like
five or ten thousand dollars
uh you'll be the exclusive sponsor for
some period of time
and if you pay me the money up front
i'll use that i'm gonna hire a video
person
an editor or whatever and then i'm gonna
do it and i'll make it uh it worth your
while why not raise money because i
don't like giving equity to people
because because you're not gonna sell it
most likely right so it's it's hard to
give equity
like in it's it's less about like equity
is bad like i obviously think equity is
good
it's more about you're basically giving
equity to an investor
that they'll never will they'll just
never be able to monetize it right
because these shows rarely actually
trade so instead what you could do is
you could say to somebody i'll give you
like a revenue share
then they actually get value out of it
so i think that but that's even a heart
that's a hard sell
so i think that just going to an
advertiser and saying hey pay me up
front and then i'll create this for you
uh that's probably the best way to go i
look a little bit like luke skywalker
today
um all right guys nba insider i hope
that was helpful if you guys have any
more questions
hashtag ask lm below don't be looking at
my emails
how did you get looking at my ebay how
do you have
four on ready because i'm about to read
them these are i'm about to be at inbox
zero again
how does that read something i have
three different emails what
do you understand i haven't been in box
zero in
years
okay i have
3 000 emails right now how do i
dang i don't know all right see you guys
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends